let's go to the first we'll do the first
clip and then I'm gonna go piggyback
right on that to the second clip Tyler
yes and I like when guys keep their cars
clean like if there's stuff all over
like trash and cups and whatever that
just kind of gives me the ick um the
make and model in year don't really
matter to me but just like
I don't know being respectful of the
things you have and you know just being
cleanly and things like that I I really
appreciate so yeah okay and we can go to
224
this is okay so first of all gives me
the ick I love it I think I'm gonna make
that into a shirt blank gives me the ick
I like I'm feeling it I'm not being
sarcastic you're gonna hear me say that
here a lot and Tyler's gonna wish that I
hadn't chosen that clip because he's
going to be here and oh that gives me
the ick a lot so get ready for it all
right this is the second part of the
cars
to me yes it's not really about like the
make and model of the car but reliable
clean
um you like take care of maintenance
the car as long as it's clean and it's
taken care of I don't think a lot of
girls would mind what kind of car he
drives if he's saving up his money to be
more responsible with his finances and
his future goals then car is not a deal
breaker okay so why did I bring this up
well you got to be clean in the car the
car is really a big deal all of the
women by the way basically I mean
there's a bunch of women in this you're
going to see a bunch of different ones
that I pull throughout but all the women
basically say we don't care if it's a
fancy car
but it can't be a car that's breaking
down all the time it can't be used as an
excuse like oh I can't come see you just
today babe my car doesn't work it's not
The Flintstones honey you know you're
not pedaling from the ground
so you got to get you got to get your
stuff together and clean okay what that
means is that when we get into your car
that car is a reflection of your space
we see it as a reflection of if we
haven't seen the apartment yet that's
probably what the apartment looks like
so if the car's scary you know you're
going to be walking into some bedroom
with dirty socks and some nasty smells
going on
and also it's like if you let us into
the car but you didn't bother to clean
it or do anything to it now we know that
you don't care about how we view your
stuff you got to be organized so car
doesn't have to be like you don't have
to be rocking in a BMW but I can tell
you one experience I'm going to share
right now I got into a car on a date
and I reached down to adjust the seat
and there was food in a plastic bag that
had gone moldy
it was Green
I was done I was like I uh I was done I
got through the date somehow but that
was the only store and to be honest with
you the guy was a really nice guy
everything else went smoothly but all I
could see was that moldy hamburger and I
was never to return
so here's what I'm saying guys can't
stink in the car by the way this goes
both ways it can't stink like rotten
food or nasty stuff and it also if you
spray up some air freshener in there to
try to cover that and then you've got
the combination of the nasty smell and
the air freshener that's not going to
work don't buy those little trees you
know you go to the car wash they're like
oh vanilla pass on that
just clean just go to the car wash you
know spend a little bit of money get
that car cleaned that's going to make a
big difference now you're going to hear
this theme throughout by the way from
the women on different topics clean they
use the word clean all the time and
you'll notice you ever been in a girl's
room you say to yourself a guy you're
like well wait a minute this clothes all
over the floor true there can be clothes
there can be clutter but it ain't dirty
dirty is different dust nasty so I'm
telling you straight up you pick her up
in a car and it's nasty on the inside
she's not coming back or she's gonna go
home she's going to tell all her friends
that your car is nasty and if you were
planning to go out with any of them you
could forget that too just saying
Tyler's car is very nice by the way I
got one ride from Tyler from this studio
to the other one you could tell Tyler's
got a woman in his life she's not gonna
get into a nasty car but Tyler is this
not true do you not feel that women need
cleanliness no I agree I'm glad you said
it goes both ways too because the
running joke is you step inside a man's
car it's always clean but his room is
filthy and you step inside a woman's car
and it's always filthy but her room is
clean yeah I've never been inside a
woman's car that isn't trashed and I
mean trash really like dirty though
dirty not just clutter dirty nasty lady
crashed okay so you can't be doing that
ladies see I I keep my stuff in order
this goes both ways by the way guy gets
well I don't know actually I honestly
think a guy could get inside a trash car
and just be like oh she's sloppy you
ever see that episode of Friends by the
way where Ross dates the girls all I can
think of the girl who's got the food
everywhere and it's like he leans down
and there's like chocolate and I'm
willing to bet I'm not gonna lie if that
girl was hot enough guys would just be
like I'll get through I'll get through
I'll just clean this chocolate and this
rat food up later I'll make it there's a
hamster in the bag and he slaps it it's
just a way and then it's dead
oh nasty here's what I'm telling you
vast majority of women though they don't
want your car to be messy like that I
don't know who's Tyler's talking about
with these girls girls are you out there
can you talk to me in the chat are you
is your car a nasty mess and now you're
expecting guys to have a clean neat car
you can't do that can't have a double
standard if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one
FaceTime with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
manect right now click right here and
let's get talking
[Music]